welcome to another episode of not too
deep we have Nicole Byer back with us
and joining her we have such year's
Amala uh they have a best friends
podcast that's so funny we talked about
them doing comedy we talked about them
and their food issues there's some
lingering food grudges between them and
we just talked about life in general
they're hilarious they're sweet they're
funny and their friendship is infectious
enjoy this episode of not too deep well
let's talk about your guys's podcast on
this podcast yeah we just found out that
you guys are coming up on your year
anniversary oh yeah I did one year one
year very exciting yeah it's also just
so nice to hear friends talk to friends
so candidly oh yeah have you guys found
that you're learning a lot about each
other no no and I would be so angry
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
things about you it makes me happy and
proud to be like yes I've heard this
story it provides new opportunities for
confrontation yeah that's fun when she
she'll bring this up often found out
years into our friendship is boring
Jordan oh hey I didn't know I had to
tell her I'm gonna win it didn't come
naturally so you know be like behind the
back okay someone outs me you know I'm
from New Jersey
I was born in New Jersey I know you're
from Indiana but you were not born there
so have you hear new information that
your assumption is that she's been
purposely withholding this from you my
brain thing which is literally insane
hey that helping you care about her so
much did I get I got in a reasonably
angry crazy
well I'm curious to know if you guys I
mean based on hearing that you don't
have all the facts about each other if
you guys have the same origin story of
your friendship like if you if someone
asks you like how did you guys become
friends do you have the same memory or
the same point of view on that I don't
know I think yes I met you tell the
story and then we can find out if you
have my ears I don't know what you're
saying oh I mean I don't mind if you
guys collaborate on a piecing the story
together
hey well okay I'm one two three we'll
say it let's say the event we first met
at you don't know well there's like a
couple that were around the same time
there is one event where we met for the
very first time okay you guys ready oh
my god okay you tell the story where you
think we first met improv show is a safe
guess both had the same improv teacher
so nosal's
at different times okay and she put
together a mashup group of women okay to
perform at a show and she put me Nicole
and Ashley award who was our improv
coach for a while and here they're
ladies on this team and it was a great
show and I guess that's where we first
but I was also thinking who's also there
was a diversity program at UCB and they
would set you up with a mentor which I
guess was like just someone who has been
at UCB four years and so somebody could
be like hey I I'm confused about this
process or whatever if you had any
advice yeah things yeah and we both have
the same mentor
Christine Engel okay blasting off into
Fame and we had like a day we had ever
seen meetups and dinner yeah like that
so everyone at McManus where we met up
with our mentor and then Christine and
introduced us both is that the first I
think that might have been the first
person actually familiar at that point I
feel like that was like still like oh
hello and then when we were on stage
together it was like a little more like
oh I've seen you before
that's what's you might be right I just
have those two flipped where we met at
the show first cuz I remember being like
wow she looks cool you wouldn't heal
I think teal bow and a goldenrod shirt
she loves goldenrod just being so funny
and I was like oh wow I like wanna be
friends with her
yeah and then I remember meeting you
again at McManus I mean like oh yeah we
did that show together but that may not
have happened the same time
okay so around this time you guys had
performed with each other and then
slowly offstage got to know each other
yes yes was there a specific point in
which like a friendship was fully
solidified that it was like we hang out
or want to hang out outside of the realm
of the theater I feel like one of the
first times we hung out outside of doing
shows was at the UCB training center
where I worked I was I worked at the
front desk and you were like oh I have
time to kill can I just sit here and I
was like yes
I mean it was like there was a good
chunk of time where we saw each other so
much it's funny that we never had a
class together because I saw you oh yeah
like we would have daytime rehearsals
improv your double ganger which is the
two of us thank you so dollar
yeah and then we would have then she
would go to work behind her go do a show
or go watch a show we get dinner and
they go home say no not even recently
where we went to dinner I wouldn't let
her leave because I was like I'm not
gonna see you for a very long time and
she's like you literally see me tomorrow
and I was like oh and let me go home and
then she texted me let me started
looking at memes together - and then we
just got on the phone because I was like
oh why text that mean kudos don't have
someone that they can have that much
necessary interaction with a regular me
on all forms what are the memes that you
guys are sending because currently now
mamrie and I and our friend Jocelyn are
all concerned and intrigued with Britney
Spears's Instagram and this red wall
that she keeps posting it yeah she's
supposed to she'll post like three to
eight photos in our all in front of this
one red wall as of right now who knows
by the time this podcast goes out what
color change is happening way mamrie
thinks she figured out what Instagram
themes are and that she's like trying to
go for one but I think she just likes
this wall I think she probably it's very
simply she likes the wall yeah I don't
really think much thought goes into what
she does yeah
sounds like a read but it's not no I
think she's had to think about her image
and herself for such a long time it's
just like whatever
yeah but what are you guys sending to
each other dog means okay Bonnie
Williams a lot of wonder William right
when you second the second season came
out there's a lot of hot music and well
speaking Wendy Williams you've been on
her show a bunch yes I have have you
ever been on one I haven't no okay you
gotta get there yeah you gotta go it
like she is very funny yeah is a very
funny woman her audience like it's like
a reverence that they have for her like
they like hang on to every word she says
yeah she's very friendly and she's like
very very funny okay um I uh I really
like her do you think I saw I guess a
couple weeks ago that she farted on air
or there was that there was a conspiracy
lowboy behind it but it just sounded
like it actual so funny yeah and I
there's part of me that thinks like that
she is in on it enough and she knows
that that's hilarious happening I also
don't know if Wendy has that wherewithal
to be like this is gonna be a funny meme
I do she just lives her life and she's
think I farted and you know what not
address her body's just so tired that
she couldn't even like hold it yeah it
came agile her there's nothing I could
do I mean her body is funny like when
she fainted I mean that wasn't funny but
the way she fainted was matter
just straight down I don't think I've
ever seen someone faint like that yeah
there's something very performative
about it yeah it feels like someone
doing a stage faint yes she's actually
she actually fainted
yeah I love Wendy um have you guys had
are you doing live shows together to
still or you've done a few shows at
Largo before of The Improv and Friends
okay I guess live do you have a
collective memory together that it was
either the best or worst I mean you guys
have done a million shows together but
anything as a recent recently they were
just so funny
we interviewed Marcellus Oh
Martellus he's a mark he's a football
player himself Marty any like Marty like
party and we're like we know Marty
that's not crazy but you interviewed
Martellus Bennett yeah and his wife okay
and it was her who knows just him and
his wife
Oh his wife came up oh yeah cuz we were
interviewing best friends and he said
something that was so funny
um he was he said to his wife if you
were in a burning building with all the
other [ __ ]
I [ __ ] I would say phew so no he said
he said this to his wife in what contact
mm-hmm that I would just to prove how
much ya know that like you loved me he's
like ah well I knew I loved her when I
was like if all of the girls I'd been
with her in a burning building I'd save
her so we did a scene based on that and
it was very funny it was so funny
because we played the [ __ ]
that's fantastic and also what a an
oddly poetic way to prove your love and
from chamber your partner yeah Wow it
was one show where they used to have a
analog clock on the side of the stage
and logo and I feel like after this they
had a digital clock well we only wanted
to go an hour yeah because I had a
flight and so we were doing in there
both of us it was so wild yeah it was we
couldn't figure out what time I mean
there's real-life consequences yeah this
imaginary yes frying imaginary eggs we
did a show in I think it was Canada okay
and we played two kids at the end of the
world we're like repopulating the world
and we just mirrored adults so I was a
little boy and I was was like oh I liked
when you told her she had to learn I
guess you it just went fully over your
head
yeah Wow I mean that means you did an
accurate job but unfortunately he's odd
bit of himself yeah Wow truth in comedy
sometimes misinterpreted you guys are
you both taking pole dancing classes yes
that how did you get into that I asked
this year to go with me because I do not
like doing things alone and I'm a big
fan of pole dancing be like Jumbo's be
like watching ladies do incredible feats
I mean yeah Jumbo's clown room is like
the artistry and I like the branding
that they are themselves is so
impressive to me yeah that's what I like
the most like I there was a moment in
time where I went to strip clubs
frequently but I think I cuz I like the
dancing yeah so much like like if I go
to a club in there just like rolling
around and like smacking their ass yeah
I don't need that trick somebody a trick
yeah yeah and so yeah when Nicole asked
you I do pull in I was like oh but it's
so hard I've heard it's really difficult
but it's like a nice tangible thing and
we're each time you do it you're like oh
I'm stronger stronger yeah do they is it
like this is the wrong reference but
like karate like is are there levels
that they're like belts are level okay
level there's first time Polar's level 1
level 2 1 2 I think 3 4 yeah
chronologically that sounds right to
9:30 to 6 ha ha you know like you kind
of have to you and and if the instructor
tells you you guys are they judge of if
you it's not like eating six weeks of
level one then you move on to level two
cuz people are at different right
strength levels and experience levels so
it's like someone may take level one and
be maybe they had dance background or
something so they at my already know how
to move ahead faster than other people
might be like I'm not comfortable even
walking in a circle
I mean the shoes are intense enough is
seeing them from you don't have to wear
them you don't I don't wear them because
I am scared I don't want to break my
ankle yeah I did my last class this girl
fell hard and I was like not even
dancing seen a better sink and I think
she just like was moving could I go walk
and she like it's scary yeah but where
are you guys now in the the levels are
experienced she's a level two only
taking one class Wow but I finally got
to move on after a year level was nice I
mean cuz you're kept being like you have
to move on and I was like I don't think
I did your personal choice to move to
the next level okay wow what an
interesting system yeah that really
makes you evaluate yourself I'm in 1/2 I
haven't a level 2 yet but that's all cuz
I've been gone for a long time okay
okay mm-hmm so consistency is a big part
of it too yeah yeah but I hadn't pulled
for like two months and then I took a
level one cuz I was like certainly I
can't just start in a level two but it
truly comes back to you so quickly oh
yeah of course this is how you do it
yeah yeah yeah what's the culture around
it like is it because you're doing it
individually it's nothing improper
you're like on a team together but
you're taking classes with people so is
it like a community kind of vibe
definitely I mean it's so supportive
yeah like we did a class where it was
more strength base and then we kind of
did like a showcase I guess for the
class so they everyone we just put my
his music on and one by one people will
dance and it's just everyone being like
like some girls are pulling out tricks
that we didn't learn in classes they
already knew and we're like I I truly
love it and I only met nice people yeah
no one's like ah man you got that trick
I want that you're like that's an insane
thought like it might never cross you're
just proud of that person for doing it
this class called low flow which not buy
it so it's a it's just like how to
move and do floor work and pull work
were you not going up we're not okay I
mean you're not inverting so it's like
that seems easy I feel like I saw a
single one or two and so I went and
these girls knew things but they were so
nice to me it's incredibly sweet it's so
nice I think it's cause like pole is
kind of like a stigmatized form of
exercise mm-hmm
that's cool it makes me want to look
into it more because it scares this you
should I've heard nothing but good
things that have taken classes and that
like your self-confidence yeah
and all of it I didn't I don't need
confidence I see the logic and how you
can do that and then you try it you're
like no okay we're gonna take a quick
break when we get back more questions
for you guys we'll be right back we're
not you deep today we have some
sponsorship from Sports
Research it's your one-stop shop for a
lifetime of performance health and
wellness they're the makers of the
highest-rated collagen peptide product
on Amazon and their flagship product
sweet sweat sweating helps burn calories
and sweet sweat activated by your
elevated heart rate helps increase
sweating during exercise you simply
apply the gel which comes in a variety
of pleasing cents too slow to respond
problem areas before you workout for
best results use sweet sweat in
combination with sports researches
best-selling waist trimmers if that's
something that you're into and did you
know that collagen is vital to support
the health of your skin hair nails and
connective tissue
shoes that's why you should try sports
researches third party certified and
non-gmo verified collagen peptides which
provide the best product at the best
price offered in a variety of flavors
sports research collagen peptides can be
added to coffee the soup de sauces or
more on the go or at home whatever you
prefer and they've sent me some of their
stuff I tried their sweet sweat one the
coconut smells amazing
I've put it on my person before I've
worked out and it does actually help
increase sweating Eliot actually uses it
every day when he works out and he looks
like a glistening God so if you're
interested I recommend we've a special
offer for you guys if you go to sports
research calm and use offer code grace
grac e at checkout right now you'll get
20% off your order that's 20% off
site-wide at sports research comm with
the promo code grace at checkout so you
guys got a hard-and-fast no from Oprah
and Gayle who did you ask just what no
no no we're surprised because let me
give you her back yeah yeah I thought
they would never respond but instead but
want to make sure that we hurt more to
know that they thought about it Liman
like we're way to know maybe Oprah was
getting her comeuppance because she is
little word come up and come up in yeah
there's a video of her talking about
balance and then she immediately loses
her balance and she falls all the way
down
it was like her Oprah Khan she's like a
big she had a big convention really oh I
didn't even know it was happening and
I'm devastated I really would right yeah
it was yeah and then she I think she
posted a video
not long after on Instagram of her like
icing her leg
I'm just being like I fell she danced
hard maybe if she'd done our podcast she
wouldn't have fallen yeah me he's gonna
be carpet in here yeah I mean I'm
holding out that baby they think about
it again
[Laughter]
who of the two of you would throw a
better house party do you think oh I
wouldn't say Nicole cuz I probably well
I think yeah oh wow I think you're
you're a good hostess and you don't get
like drunk you cuz you would most likely
throw a party where I would know that is
a key element to that yeah I have a bit
of social anxiety but I we did have a
party recently it was like a joint party
with our neighbors in the yard that we
share and I was a good house I mostly
took out trash and I love doing that
because I didn't talk to anybody
hmmm that's great get yourself a tag
yeah I wish I could I was like she is
really cleaning you yeah you kept
bouncing in and out with like bags of
trash hey what did I take a rib from you
I was furious
and I ran to the grill and I found no
idea your whole demeanor changed that's
very sweet
it shows that you care you guys are
working on a screenplay together can you
give any details about it or is it
confidential as it's in the works
I should I don't think we should either
but people can just know you're working
yes yeah yeah yeah like you guys must
collaborate on all kinds of things yeah
yeah is there something you haven't done
yet that it's been like talked about
grandiose ideas dumb or totally
legitimate no I think we like pretty
much follow through and everything well
we did want to turn pursuit of sexiness
into a TV show but I think that's maybe
you have sailed that ship maybe have
sailed maybe yes
okay that was a bad sentence would you
guys go on a reality competition show
together and if so which one do you
think yes I would but like 10 15 years
from now okay maybe now it'd be paid an
extraordinary amount of money let's say
all the keys were in place I know that
all your needs were met with this
potential of you going on a reality game
show which one would do you think you
would either do the best at or most want
to go on I'm going wipeout oh yeah
never seen white well what's a group I
guess like Amazing Race that seems like
a lot of work we may be good at it
because I feel like you would be great
at like strategy and um like figuring
out how to win mm-hmm doing the thing
you know yeah a good balance yes that is
a lot of our relationship maybe like I
don't know how to make this a thing but
here's idea yeah so you'd be like we
need to get to Switzerland for next clue
but I don't know how to get there okay
[Laughter]
wait sure weren't you on the celebrity
game show recently or something I saw
something of you and Joey Fatone yes 25
words or less yeah what is that they
provide it's a it's a game show it's
like I guess it's based off a board game
or like actual okay the people who play
where you get a word uh-huh and then you
have to get your teammates to guess that
word using 25 words or less I see okay
and I'm really good at this game okay so
okay an example would be okay I have a
word and I'm gonna try to use less than
six words to let get you guys okay okay
and this is a person or is just a word
it's a word okay okay as long as it
can't be people okay okay
sink spout faucet faucet yes
okay this is I see this is who I think
I'd be bad at it I would be really bad I
get very frustrated you doing okay
I come up with a word and then have to
give less than six words we're doing
what even make oh now that else other
thing you had you can make your own
parameters but you since you were going
up against another person you were kind
of like facing off to see who can get
less so like you would basically like
I'm sure I can get and you had the same
word so yeah oh I think I can get this
Fawcett word if under under 12 in the
other person be like so it's like name
that tune yet with words it's a game
with the the song that you're like I'm
gonna I bet I can guess this song in
three notes yeah get that with you a lot
[Laughter]
I was listening me guys this podcast and
you just you're doing Transcendental
Meditation yeah yeah how is that going
it's going well and what is
Transcendental Meditation exactly you
know I don't know if I know it's like
this is a different type of meditation
okay that kind of affects your mind and
your actual physiology like I do feel
less stressed like truly after my first
session I walked out and I was like I
don't know if I did that right
and then I branded like saw someone
going to the grocery store and they were
like you look astonishing oh wow yeah
what were you wearing gold and wrong I
some gold in the outfit but yeah I just
it just feels it just i've tried
meditation in other ways like I've tried
apps tried doing it after yoga and it
just didn't feel it just wasn't for me
yeah
so this for this I like this because it
made it seem really easy mm-hmm and then
in order to do it you take these courses
you do four consecutive courses and I I
don't know what their reasoning is to do
that but I like doing it four days in a
row because it really drilled in the
habit yeah yeah of doing it twice a day
cuz if I if there if I just read it
online and it was like oh that's what
you do then I'd be like all right I'll
get to it when I get to it yeah but
because I had to go physically go
somewhere every day and they're like did
you do the thing and then I was like
yeah I had to yeah but yeah I like it a
lot I do feel a little calmer and yeah
definitely less I'm slower to get angry
that's great that's wonderful if you
could take my rib yeah probably would
have been like you know yeah I don't
know maybe I was the food like it is all
pieces of the wild how much of like a
monster you can come when you're hungry
or like food is not what you expected
and you're just like I just love eating
so much and if someone Dupre's me to
know in a friendship I would love to
read just a book of your harrowing tales
of not getting full
I would yeah okay we're gonna take one
last break when we get back we have a
ton of Twitter questions for you guys
we'll be ready so we're all in it we're
all going through it right now and
here's something that might be able to
help you out you're stuck at home
feeling isolated worried about the state
of the world in your life and your
relationships it's better help they
offer online professional counselors who
can help you can talk to a licensed
online therapist and find relief better
help therapists specialize in issues
like depression stress anxiety
relationships and saamne family
conflicts basically every single thing
that all of us are experiencing at the
current moment I know that I've been
going through peaks and valleys highs
and lows ups and downs all of it and
having someone to talk to it's just such
a relief even for the most minor things
conversationally or the most deep major
things conversationally you can connect
with your counselor in a safe and
private online environment anything you
share is confidential you simply fill
out a questionnaire to help assess your
needs and you get matched with a
counselor that you'll love in less than
24 hours you can easily schedule secure
video or phone sessions with your
therapist plus exchange unlimited
messages and if for any reason you're
unhappy with your counselor you can
request a new one at anytime for no
additional charge you can get
professional help when you want it
wherever you are better help is a truly
affordable option and you guys will get
10% off your first month with the
discount code grace so why not get
started today go to better help calm
slash grace that's better help calm
slash grace discount code grace talk to
a therapist online and get help
okay we're gonna get into these Twitter
questions but before we do I'm gonna ask
you as the two questions asked every
single guest that's on the podcast
the first is who alive or dead would you
most want to throw cold spaghetti at oh
it's your choice you can determine your
intention behind it okay
and this you know could change on a
daily basis so this is just in this
moment does it have like marinara sauce
on it also your choice oh yeah dealer's
choice
hmm because they're truly thinking right
I love spaghetti
I really do love it pulls be Eddy
sometimes and I'm like if has meatballs
in it and I was like maybe I throw it
like Harriet Tubman because I really
like share some delicious food with hard
work I keep trying to erase our history
[Applause]
maybe I would throw it at Eminem okay
yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and he has verbally confirmed that he
has particular Yeti we must like it yeah
okay the other question that I ask every
guest is to tell us your worst pants
shooting story or close call but you can
only use three words or three small
phrases so mine is college jogging front
lawn oh dang yeah mmm and it can be a
close call it doesn't have to be
specifically pants [ __ ] can be any
sort of body
malfunction mmm okay castor oil okay Wow
tender greens banquette period blood
whoa don't know tender greens is it okay
Prometheus fire wants to know if you
guys use reddit do you have a guilty
pleasure subreddit if not do you have
other social media guilty pleasures mmm
do you guys use reddit yeah yeah oh look
at reddit when someone goes look at this
awful thing someone wrote about you
because people do that
oh yeah you go there you're like nobody
likes me but what's your when you open
up your phone if you go to your apps
like what's your social media of choice
like what are you on more likely than
the other Instagram yeah yeah we love
Instagram that's what I put a timer on
it recently did you I'm not on it for
more than two hours a day cuz that
hasn't been helpful it has been helpful
and sometimes I don't even recent limit
and I'm like
[Laughter]
I'd be afraid I'd have the opposite but
I would feel like I'm on there for ten
minutes and it'd be like you've reached
your limit yeah like I'm a monster
right there are times where I've hit the
limit in the morning and it's like a day
just ignore it
yeah that's fair that's get me into tick
tock have you luck is fun is that you on
it I'm not on it cuz I don't I'm not
gonna make videos for tick tock what you
think no but yeah I have an account okay
I creep you can explore pages learning
what I like I opened it up and I look at
and then I close it because it feels
like unter uncharted territory yeah
exactly and I couldn't get into vine cuz
I just didn't know I didn't spend enough
time trying to be here to watch vine
compilations on YouTube like here are
dogs in 2019 perfect but what's on
tick-tock what's your what's your go-to
black kids they're very funny like young
black youth they're scary and funny and
I say scary cuz they'll roast you and
you like I feel bad about yourself like
when you're on the train sometimes
they'll just laugh at you and you're
like and it cuts so deep someone wants
to know MC wj4 if you guys were on the
Real Housewives
what would your tagline be mmm it's a
tough one what are the tag lines usually
nene leakes the her first season was
when I walk into a room I own it and
then one of the Beverly Hills housewives
I think their first season was diamonds
aren't a girl's best friend
freedom is I love dogs but I can't deal
with [ __ ]
like okay mmm they're all little
self-deprecating but I'm like very
self-serving if you promise me food you
better give it to me
don't walk near me my labia will wrap
you up nope while I used to say this
joke on stage if you can't stand the
heat get out of my [ __ ] that's great
that is a tagline I feel like Erika
Jayne would say something on the line
she's great you gotta watch her music
maybe I have oh yeah she's literally
perfect she's on Brooke Candy's new
album or EP and it's a great song her
whole it's like star gasm I think that's
what it's called
it's 30 minutes it's great it's such a
Brooke and she has the best one-liners
on the show like in her Talking Heads
they're so great and then it's just her
sipping champagne like through a straw
between everything someone's asking
what's the experience like being in film
fest versus cameos comedy shows for
current TV roles what repite the
experience of being in film fest for the
weekend
oh yeah versus cameos comedy shows or
recurring TV roles
okay I was in a movie called the weekend
mm-hmm that you can watch on Amazon hey
cap Apple or most other places and yeah
we went to be did the festival run with
that movie and and I've been the fest
other festivals with other movies and I
like it a lot yeah it's fun it's fun to
sit in the audience and hear people
watch your step and also be like look at
whatever else is doing - yeah I hear my
peers doing cool stuff as well yeah I
enjoy the process and I like indie
movies because it feels like everyone
involved he's doing it for the love of
it yeah yeah and yeah we also want
people
watch it sure but it feels like there's
an actual like everyone's putting in
their best efforts and then once genuine
like success from every angle also
Congrats Nicole you have a pilot for NBC
thank you awesome congratulations yeah
what how was that difference between
doing something like nailed it versus
doing a scripted I mean it must be a
nice breath of fresh air yeah nailed it
really only takes up like 13 or 14 days
out of my ear
Wow because we shoot one episode a day
mm-hmm but it's kind of it's unscripted
in a way we're like all our interactions
are unscripted but like when I'm
explaining the cookies or whatever
that's like that's scripted in the
prompter but um yeah acting is just
different
I can make different choices that I
can't really make as a host right you
know if I was like let me do it and so
she was telling us a little bit before
you got here about your prepping for
your special yes go to record your
special do you guys like do you work
dearie get Nicole's opinion or feedback
on stuff like that when you guys work on
projects that aren't the ones that
you're you know on paper working on
together yeah we'll do it run by each
other like we each other's scripts or
whatever the thing is because I trust
her opinion yeah yeah I know she I know
she knows my sense of humor and soon
like it's super super helpful to have
someone yeah already knows your work and
is what you're capable of and has an
opinion on what you're doing yeah are
you excited for her special taping of
course I went to her first special
taping and it was I mean not to be corny
but like special it was like very
special we were in New Orleans with like
a bunch of friends and I just like knew
how much work you would put into it you
found this beautiful blue outfit to wear
you look stunning
you were like loose in a way that I was
like ah she's
and it was just like really amazing to
watch and it's fun to watch a friend see
all of their work culminate into like a
special or like the weekend like all the
movies you've done like the guest spots
you'd like it's just it's really
exciting to watch your friend thrive
right especially when you know their
potential - funniest people I know oh
that's so sweet
when other people like I met a director
that you worked with yesterday
and I was oh so sure did that with you
and he was like yes she's so funny I was
like that's so sweet
okay Matthew wants to know if it was
your last day on earth
what would you to do before it was all
over let's say you guys had to spend
your last day together we'd probably get
food yeah maybe like get in my pool and
be like last tip yeah I don't think we I
don't know we've had a lot of fun so I
don't think I'd be like we have to go do
one last fun thing yeah yeah I think we
would kill that's a very nice honest we
wouldn't do anything out of the norm
yeah Julie what we really like yeah
that's why we want to end out end my
life on things that I already know I
really enjoy the world
we'll have our perfect day hey why did
you get into cooking cuz I don't really
neither one of us really cook okay and I
found an Instagram recipe and I was like
this year we gotta make this recipe and
she's like okay and then we get to the
supermarket and I go okay we gotta watch
the video to get the ingredients this
she's like you didn't write down things
like nah did
they're watching this 30-second video
over and over again just shouting out
there I'm writing them down this is like
garlic I feel like this is a great train
anything Danny should have to watch this
in Xalapa and then at one point in the
supermarket it's this year parsley is
green
we are already established before that
point we can't you know it was some sort
of noodles okay so you say don't need a
parsley parsley and then we she passes
the parsley as you know what does partly
look like like how are we supposed to
find it I don't even know what color is
she answered the question I never
happened I was like cool
how did the actual meal turn out okay I
was like pretty pleased with it and I
was telling this to Matteo and he was
like oh you probably could have just
gotten to the link in the bio and it had
all the recipes there and I was like
video so many more views this one video
did people like the pasta parsley
okay last question star fan wants to
know how do you guys get used to such
constant travelling
she said Nicole I know you were just in
Buffalo and I missed it yeah I was in
Buffalo I mean well it must be nice you
guys travel we talked a little bit about
this that you guys travel so much it
must be nice to look forward to having
the podcast to come back and look at the
time with each other yes yes I mean we
do talk so much when we're on the road
we still call each other yeah and we
never lose content in front of each
other have you guys developed any sort
of like shorthand in terms of like like
mamrie and Hannah and I tried at one
point to figure out like an emoji that
we could all decide on that if we send
it to each other like if the group chat
was going really long one of us sends
this and so the other two no I'm not
ignoring this I'm just busy right now
and I short-handed thinking and we never
decided on one when she doesn't answer i
text in all caps excuse me you guys are
like helicopter parents or or we're
texting each other and then like we
should just be talking and I call her
and she's a pig I'm like Hello tell me
[Laughter]
casual aggression for whatever reason
like I'm not gonna see you until April I
think you guys
I love this live both on the like thin
ice that your friend very sweet thank
you guys so much for being here before
we wrap up everything completely I want
to give you guys every guest that makes
time gets a personalized fortune cookie
from us to you guys
you open it now yes you can open it now
and read the fortune that's inside
everything's been sanitized like a
wishbone we actually went back and asked
a friend Gail to see if they were really
sure about not wanting to be on your
podcast where can people find everything
that you guys are up to catch up to a
million things if they don't know yes on
social media Instagram and Twitter I'm
at Nicole Byer we are podcast best
friends I have another one called why
won't you date me another one called new
comers where I watch Star Wars with
Lauren lapkus another one called drag
her with Monogue a few more we watch
RuPaul's Drag Race
another Marci Giroux call 90 day Bay
it's only on patreon we watch 90 day
fiancé the greatest I love that show on
the history of television I have a
special on Netflix and they nailed it on
Netflix
oh I read a book and I have a papi it's
available for pre-sale now yes and it's
got a long beautiful title
I wrote down yes wow I love it well very
fat very brave the fat girls guide to
being brave and not a dejected
melancholy down in the dumps weeping fat
girl in a bikini but it's one thing to
see it online the tiny like intact
identity on the cover of the book
actually makes it very wonderful
congratulation for presale now yes it's
available for presale and the links and
my BIOS on Instagram and Twitter and you
know you can go to I think Barnes Noble
or Amazon all the places awesome
congratulations
ok exciting is this year where can
people find everything I mostly post
about my tour dates on Instagram or
Twitter and both of those are at the
sheer truth to be H e sheer truth V like
th EE to share the truth when you're
listening to the word though some people
might think of saying like a muscle
shear hope somebody is like I'm gonna
fall th e CH sh e ER t ru th a comm you
watched my last special pizza mind on
Amazon and other things I'm sure and
also the album is on Spotify and iTunes
and the weekend is on Amazon and iTunes
and I think anyone listening can never
complain aboard embed less hours of
canto
people to absorb much content well
that's wonderful again thank you guys
for making time and being here so fun go
listen to their podcasts go check out
every piece of media that they have out
there available for you and we'll see
you guys next time on another episode of
not too deep good bye bye bye too deep
toady totemic not too deep is a
production of grace helbig incorporated
producer Melissa Dee months edited by
Shireen Lonnie Eunice post production
sound by Chris Henry and an extra
special thanks to Flula for the theme
music
[Music]